STILL JUST TEN POINTS FOR
MIDDLETON, TEN POINTS FOR
HOLIDAY, AND A TEN-POINT DEFICIT
FOR THE BUCKS.
LOPEZ WITH THE STEAL.
CRAIG NEARLY GOT IT BACK, BUT
TEAGUE COMES UP WITH THE LOOSE
BALL.
CONNAUGHTON FAKES.
AYTON.
TEAGUE, WIDE-OPEN THREE-POINTER.
ANTETOKOUNMPO, ANOTHER OFFENSIVE
REBOUND, AND HAMMERED ONCE
AGAIN.
>> Mark: HE'S DOING A
OUTSTANDING JOB OF ATTACKING THE
OFFENSIVE BOARDS.
YOU'RE PHOENIX YOU'RE DOING THE
RIGHT THING, REBOUNDING AND
TYING THEM UP TO MAKE FREE
THROWS.
YOU DON'T GET THE BASKETBALL,
PROBLEM, YOU'RE PLAYING SMALL,
NOT SURROUNDING YOU WITH BODIES,
OFFENSIVE REBOUND.
>> Jeff: THE ONLY THING I WOULD
SAY ABOUT HIM IN COMPARISON TO
LOPEZ, LOPEZ KEEPS IT UP HIGH
AND FINISHES HIGH.
GIANNIS